[Musique]
merci Pascal grenier n accompagn pendant
cette première demi-heure vous êtes élu
den membre du groupe les républiquain et
vice-présidente de la Commission des
affaires sociales on va évidemment
longuement parler de cette colère du
monde agricole les agriculteurs qui
veulent faire le siège de Paris et
bloquer également d'autres grandes
agglomérations il y a des barrages dans
de nombreux points du pays est-ce que
vous approuvez cet objectif faire le
siège de parisah pourquoi pas Paris en
fait voilà parce que finalement le
d'ailleurs le ministre Marc F hier j'ai
trouvé que quand il disait qu'il fallait
pas venir bloquer Paris on l'a fait
aussi en province il parle des
entreprises qui vont être dérangées nous
aussi on a des entreprises sont
dérangées en revanche il y a vraiment
une crise agricole c'est vous pensez
peut-être que c'est la colère moi
j'appelle là le désespoir voilà parce
qu'il y a vraiment eu des attentes et
des propositions le Sénat a fait fait
des propositions depuis des années moi
j'en ai fait au sein de la commission
des affaires européennes et on a rien
donc au bout d'un moment quand on ne
mange pas à sa fin ben voilà on est
obligé de descendre dans la rue
malheureusement on va revenir sur le
fond sur les revendications sur les
mesures mais sur ces blocages Marc fen
il pointait hier le risque d'un
retournement de l'opinion publique qui
jusqu'à maintenant est favorable au
mouvement des agriculteurs mais il dit
s'il y a trop de blocage l'opinion
publique peut se retourner contre les
agriculteurs il a pas raison alors c'est
c'est possible he mais je pense que pour
l'instant justement la population est
derrièrees ces agriculteurs parce que
ils ont conscience quand même que ceux
qui les nourrissent ce ce sont eux donc
c'est le gouvernement en fait qui doit
répondre parce que on a eu des premières
annonces on nous on nous dit qu'on va en
avoir d'autres mais il faut des actes
aujourd'hui il y a Gérald armanin qui
jusqu'à maintenant n n'est pas intervenu
sur sur ces blocages je vous poserai une
question là-dessus dans quelques
instants mais hier il a annoncé 15000
policiers et gendarmes pour empêcher que
les tracteurs entrent dans les grandes
villes et il demande quand même de ne
pas intervenir il demande aux forces de
l'ordre de ne pas intervenir sur les
points de blocage de simplement les
sécuriser euh c'est une c'est la bonne
méthode pour vous oui c'est la bonne
méthode Gérald haranan ministre de
l'Intérieur il est tout à fait dans dans
son rôle mais quand vous entendez aussi
les syndicats ils espèrent que ces
manifestation se se fasse dans le calme
mais parfois je vous dis il y a des gens
tellement désespérés qu'on on peut avoir
à des endroits ou à d'autres un
mouvement qui soit plus violent mais le
ministre de l'Intérieur a eu raison de
ne pas intervenir jusque là y compris
quand il y avait des dégradations de
bâtiments publics parce qu'il y en a eu
dans plusieurs villes à nî à Carcassonne
à agin il a eu raison de de laisser
faire ah oui moi je trouve que oui il a
raison aussi de de laisser s'exprimer en
fait ce ce désespoir des des
agriculteurs sans intervenir et puis je
pense que Gérald daranin c'est aussi un
élu de terrain et il connaît les bien
les agriculteurs en fait on va parler
des des mesures des réponses du
gouvernement une première série de
réponses vendredi de la part de Gabriel
hatal est-ce que les mesures qui ont été
annoncées ont été les bonnes pour vous
alors elles sont insuffisantes alors
d'ailleurs le premier ministre parle
beaucoup de la simplification
administrative bon très bien on espère
moi chaque fois qu'ils ont que j'ai vu
des simplification ça a toujours été
pire derrière mais en revanche ça
n'amène rien dans le revenu agricole
après il y a des délais pour les les
recours idem je veux dire tout ça c'est
c'est beaucoup de
bavardage mais ça ça n'amène rien
l'Office de la biodiversité de le mettre
sous la coupe du du préfet ça c'est très
bien c'est très c'est très attendu le
Gasol le Gasol nonti le GNR en fait moi
j'ai interrogé syndicat hier c'est 150 €
pour la ferme moyenne par an c'est est
pas vraiment suffisant mais c'était
quand même un des un des points de
blocage pour les agriculteurs cette
fiscalité sur le gazol non routier il a
eu raison de cider Gabriel Atal et de
revenir en arrière finalement ah benah
oui c'est ça faut pas en ajouter mais je
veux dire que là ils ont laissé
tellement monter en fait cette cette
colère ce ce désespoir que aujourd'hui
les agriculteurs demandent tout ce qu'il
demandent depuis depuis longtemps et et
en fait on va dire que l'étincelle ça a
été le Gasol mais aujourd'hui il demande
autre chose et notamment les prix on n
rien eu sur les prix on va y revenir il
a trop tardé à réagir le gouvernement il
y a quelques semaines on a vu ces
opérations panneau à l'envers de la part
des agriculteurs dans plusieurs villes
et villages pour vous le gouvernement
aurait dû intervenir à ce
moment-là à ce moment-là mais bien bien
avant nous on a fait beaucoup de
propositions en fait propositions de de
loi parfois votter ici au Sénat donc il
y a jamais jamais eu d'écoute
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qui qui
découvre mais non c'est quelque chose
qui couvre depuis des années et puis
derrière vous avez aussi le mépris en
fait de de la ruralité qui a existé
depuis trop longtemps euh de la part de
la part de qui de ce de ce gouvernement
et du du président que Gabriel Atal hier
il fustigé les discours qui
stigmatisaient les agriculteurs
notamment ceux qui traitaent les
agriculteurs de pollueurs visant on
l'imagine les écologistes oui oui il a
eu raison ah bah ça ça oui il a raison
parce que surtout quand on connaît bien
l'agriculture moi je vais vous dire que
si chaque Français avait fait les mêmes
effort que les agriculteurs et bien on
n'en serait pas où on en est aujourd'hui
ça fait 20 ans que les agriculteurs ont
changé leur pratique qui diminuent les
phytosanitaires le les les engrais il
mettent juste ce qu'il faut enfin euh
les Français n'ont pas fait ça euh dans
leur maison ouz on va continuer
justement à parler des des propositions
celle du gouvernement et celle de la
droite sénatoriale qui ont été remises
sur la table la semaine dernière on voit
ça avec notre journaliste Alex
[Musique]
Poussard bonjour Alex bonjour ran
bonjour Pascal bonjour et Alex les
sénateurs les républicains font des
propositions pour répondre à la crise
agricole et oui les sénateurs LR vont
déposer une nouvelle proposition de loi
sur l'agriculture avec 42 mesures pour
essayer d'améliorer le quotidien de nos
agriculteurs 42 mesures plus plusieurs
piliers d'abord un premier pilier qui
vise à soutenir les agriculteurs face à
ce qu'ils appellent du harcèlement et de
la stigmatisation il propose de mieux
lutter contre les intrusions sur les
parcelles agricoles il propose également
d'interdire les dons à certaines
associations écologistes qui
réaliseraient des actions contre les
agriculteurs et qui se mettraient hors
la loi ou encore il souhait limiter les
recours des riverins face aux
exploitations agricoles deuxième pilier
à simplifier les normes c'est un sujet
qu'on entend beaucoup en ce moment
notamment également de la part du
gouvernement simplifier les normes
auxquelles font face les agriculteurs
Laurent Duplomb le sénateur les
républicains et chef de fil sur ces
questions agricoles veut créer ce qu'il
appelle une commission de désherbage des
normes qui reprendrait toutes les lois
précédentes et sur l'agriculture et
supprimerait les normes qui aujourd'hui
complique la vie de nos agriculteurs et
puis la droite sénatoriale veut
assouplir les règles environnementale
elle propose de réautoriser certains
néonicotinoïdes en France ces
insecticides tueur d'abeilles en donnant
également pour les sénateurs LR et bien
un caractère d'intérêt général au
stockage de l'eau pour les agriculteur
c'est-à-dire en défendant les
mégabassines et puis concernant l'Office
français de la biodiversité l'ofb vous
en avez parlé Pascal Gruny cet office il
est pointé du doigt par les agriculteurs
le gouvernement a annoncé sa mise sous
tutelle par les préfets et bien les
sénateurs les républicains proposent
tout simplement de supprimer l'ofb
écoutez laurend
duplom on ne peut plus conserver un
office qui n'est plus un office qui peut
rendre des services mais qui est
uniquement dans le contrôle et dans le
contrôle stigmatique de l'agriculture et
des agriculteurs l'ofb devait s'occuper
de la chasse et de l'eau l'ofb
aujourd'hui ne s'occupe uniquement de
verbaliser les actions des agriculteurs
c'est qu'il ne comprennent plus c'est
quand l'ofb par exemple verbalise des
agriculteurs qui débroussaillent le bord
de leur parcelle pour garder l'entretien
de leur
parce que pour l'ofb c'est la
destruction d'un habitat ou la
destruction d'une œil qui n'existe pas
et puis dernier pilier de ces mesures
proposé par la droite sénatoriale la
relance de la compétitivité de
l'agriculture française avec et bien la
reprise d'une proposition de loi qui a
été votée l'an dernier au Sénat ce texte
prévoyait la création d'abord d'un
livret d'épargne agriculture pour aider
à financer les investissements des
exploitations agricoles il proposait
également des baisses d'impôts et de
cotisation sociale et la création d'un
haut commissa ser à la compétitivité des
filières agricoles auprès du ministre de
l'Agriculture ce Haut commissaire et
bien centraliserait toutes les demandes
tous les problèmes de compétitivité des
différentes filières agricoles Pascal
Greny une question sur cette notion
d'image et de stigmatisation des
agriculteurs on a l'impression quand
même que les Français aiment les
agriculteurs leurs agriculteurs et
pourtant il a il y a ce problème de
stigmatisation la faute à
qui je dirais à l'écoute qu'on fait aux
écologistes que j'appelle plutôt les
écolos
d'ailleurs parce que sans arrê viennent
les pointer du doigt je peux vous dire
que même chez nous les agriculteurs qui
se font photographier quand ils sortent
le leur pulvérisateur enfin ça devient
vraiment compliqué on appelle ça l'agri
bashing et c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose de compliqué donc les Français
aiment leurs agriculteurs une partie
mais je crois que des fois ils oublient
pardon ils oublient aussi en fait
justement qu'il les less ont aimé et
puis ça revient très très vite et puis
sans arrêt je veux dire les mettre en
cause c'est facile parce que finalement
on regarde plus ce que nous on pollue
personnellement et cetera donc donc je
crois que là effectivement il faut il
faut les aider les intrusions dans dans
les fermes c'est violent parliez tout à
l'heure justement des manifestations
mais c'est bien plus violent quand quand
vous avez des des personnes des
associations qui rentrent dans dans les
dans les fermes et qui sa cage en fait
les fermes ça c'est insupportable
pourquoi déposer une proposition lo
maintenant alors que le gouvernement
travaille sur un projet de loi
agriculture qui aurait d'ailleurs dû
être présenté la semaine dernière en
conseil des ministres et qui a été
reporté pour ajouter de nouvelles
mesures h bah parce que on fait on a
toujours fait des propositions de loi et
là dans dans les on espère les quelques
mesures que qui vont être prises par le
gouvernement sont des propositions qu'on
a qu'on a déjà fait précédemment leurend
duplom c'est pas aujourd'hui qu'il a
déposé une proposition de loi il
complète les propositions de loi qui ont
été faites au auparavant donc donc voilà
ça ça nous aide toujours après de mettre
de se saisir de cette de ces
propositions de loi pour amender le
texte qui qui va être ramené par le
gouvernement estce pous pas le curseur
un peu loin les propositions de loi des
républicains vous pensez qu'elle pourra
être reprise par le gouvernement ben on
espère on espère beaucoup en fait puis
que le Conseil constitutionnel viendra
pas les supprimer voilà on va reparler
petite référence à la loi immigration
alors dans les mesures que vous proposez
il y a la suppression pure et simple de
l'Office français de la biodiversité ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que la
préservation de l'environnement c'est un
frein à l'activité agricole aujourd'hui
mais ça devrait pas les agriculteurs
franchement comment vous pouvez-vous
imaginer que les
agriculteurs ne font pas attention à la
terre aux animaux et cetera ils font
tout ils sont ils sont chasseurs aussi à
côté euh donc donc non franchement moi
je pense que sur tout ce qui est
environnement je pense que on pourrait
suivre ce que ce que ce qu'on proposait
les agriculteurs depuis longtemps à un
moment donné moi j'ai travaillé en
centre de gestion agricole c'est vrai
que le niveau des phytosanitaires et des
engrais moi c'était dans les années 80
était énorme mais c'était les conseils
qui étaient donnés par les ingénieurs
agricoles aujourd'hui les
phytosanitaires d'abord sont très très
chers comme comme comme les engrais et
ils ont ils ont besoin aussi d' avoir de
la compétitivité si on leur fait
d'autres propositions sur des des
pratiques ou des des produits qui vont
être moins cher ils vont le faire et en
plus si c'est si ça concerne
l'environnement bien évidemment qu'il
mais est-ce qu'on a trop donné priorité
à l'écologie au détriment de
l'agriculture ah oui ça c'est vrai et ça
et ça c'est aussi au niveau de la la
Commission européenne moi j'ai je ça
fait des années là que je dis c'est trop
vite trop fort voilà et puis en plus pas
de recherche pas d'innovation
suffisamment d'ailleurs mais là le
gouvernement dit pas d'interdiction sans
solution ça c'est le bon principeou ah
bah oui c'est le bon principe verbal ça
suit pas bah dans les actions non dans
les actions non on a plus de 150
produits interdits en France par rapport
à ce qui
est autorisé dans les autres pays
européens de l'Union européenne donc
donc non il faut arrêter la
surtransposition ici en France bah oui
bien sûr donc justement vous dit ça va
trop vite cette transition écologique il
faut donc reculer et réautoriser
certains néonicotinoïdes tueur d'abeill
oui alors sur sur sur les abeilles on
pourra en parler hein parce que il y a
pas que les agriculteurs he pas du tout
moi je vais vous dire sur sur les
betterales je sais pas si vous avez déjà
offert un bouquet de fleur à votre
conjoint
conjointe non mais de fleurs de bérave
fleurs de BVE voilà bon voilà donc en
fait on attend pas que la betterave elle
fleurisse moi j'ai jamais vu de fleurs
de betterave donc voilà aujourd'hui par
exemple sur le colsa il y a des fleurs
effectivement donc là on met pas de
néonicotinoïde mais il y a des des
plantes qui en ont besoin le le sucre
ben c'est important c'est c'est une
filière très
importante il y a je sais plus c'était 3
ans ou 4 ans on a eu la jaunice et on a
eu une récolte franchement qui était
presque nul donc donc il faut soutenir
nos filières alors on dit qu'on fait
plus de betterrave mais sauf que la la
préoccupation écologique elle est de
plus en plus importante dans l'opinion
et notamment dans la jeune génération
est-ce qu'il y a pas un risque de couper
les agriculteurs de l'opinion est-ce
qu'il faut forcément opposer agriculture
et écologie non par dit que les
agriculteurs sont les les les premiers
écologistes mais oui mais mais bien sûr
donc c'est pour ça il faut faut
absolument pas les les les opposer
simplement il faut accompagner il faut
faire de la recherche de l'innovation
donner des produits de subs tion qu'on n
pas toujours voilà peut-être trait t
moins aujourd'hui on enlève des produits
et tout à l'heure je vous parlais des
pulvérisateurs aujourd'hui on a enlevé
des produits du coup les agriculteurs
ils pulvérisent trois fois quatre fois
plus ils sortent il sortent leur
matériel trois ou quatre fois plus mais
finalement au niveau de de l'air qu'on
qu'on respire c'est bien plus comment
dangereux que finalement d'avoir soigné
la r directement en fait donc c'est pour
ça et des fois voyez des des mesures qui
sont proposées on les comprend pas les
agriculteurs ne comprennent pas moi moi
hier dans mes cérémonies de vœux on m'a
parlé ça de sortir le pulvérisateur
plusieurs fois c'est un agriculteur donc
donc voilà je pense que les les
solutions les agriculteurs ils en ont
ils veulent bien
accompagner mais il faut aussi qu'on les
aide il y a pas eu un mot sur la
recherche et l'innovation
c'est très important on parle des
produits mais on peut parler aussi du
matériel il y a du matériel aujourd'hui
où vous pouvez soigner juste la plante
qui est malade et pas celle qui est à
côté ça coûte combien qui peut investir
dans du matériel comme ça c'est c'est là
l'État doit aider les agriculteurs il
faut accompagner oui justement sur la
question des revenus parce que c'est
c'est un des des autres points le le
faible revenu de beaucoup d'agriculteurs
et notamment le respect de la loi et
Galim Gabriel Atal et Bruno Lemer
promettent des contrôles promettent des
sanctions pour ceux qui ne respectent
pas cette loi qui est censé rééquilibrer
les relations entre les agriculteurs et
la grande distribution est-ce que vous
saluez la fermeté du gouvernement sur le
sujet et est-ce que c'est suffisant ou
est-ce qu'il faut revoir la loi ben
c'est surtout que les promesses mais il
fallait pas faire les promesses fallait
mettre en application justement les les
les lois égalimes les contrôles
aujourd'hui on nous dit on va faire on
va faire davantage de contrôle bah
pourquoi vous les vous avez pas fait
avant on va faire davantage de sanctions
là avec les manifestations j'ai lu qu'il
y avait trois grandes entreprise là
qu'on va sanctionner mais s'il y avait
pas eu les manifestations on les aurait
sanctionné alors Mar F dit que pour
qu'elle soit sanctionné aussi vite c'est
bien que les dossiers étaient instruits
avant et que du coup ça ne date pas de
la la de la de la mobilisation oui bien
sûr bien sûr bon c'est pas c'est pas ce
c'est pas ce qu'on pense c'est par ce
que j'ai lu aussi et en fait là le
gouvernement vis-à-vis des agriculs
c'est la confiance qui
manque la
retraite La retraite calculée sur les 25
meilleures années on l'a voté en février
2023 à l'intérieur de ce de ce texte que
j'ai porté avec mon collègue Julien d' à
l'Assemblée nationale on a fait un
conform pour aller vite fallait rendre
un rapport sous 3 mois bon 3 mois c'est
peut-être un peu court mais aujourd'hui
il est pas sorti là le Premier ministre
hier il disait mais si si il est là
c'est c'est imminent oui c'est bien et
après il faut les décrets et la MSA elle
est prête donc l'amélioration de la
retraite des agriculteurs n'est toujours
pas appliquée par le gouvernement non et
ça fait un an et ça fait un an et tout
est comme ça donc c'est la confiance en
fait donc on peut faire des beaux
discours là on en a vu avec le Premier
ministre mais derrière moi quand je l'ai
regardé j'ai dit oui et les
actes merci Alex tout à l'heure tout à
l'heure on parlera des réactions
politiques sur cette crise agricole on
verra qu'il y a un petit peu de
récupération ce sera su dans le club on
va continuer à parler de ce sujet ça
fait aussi l'actualité dans votre
département de laine Pascal grunny où on
va retrouver Jean-Marc chevaucher
bonjour Jean-Marc merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous rédacteur en chef adjoint du
Courrier Picard et dans le Courrier
Picard on parle toujours de révolte
paysane on va se replonger dans
l'histoire avec vous
ouais Orian on a choisi de titrer la
grande Jacquerie à la Une de notre
journal ce matin puisque la grande
Jacquerie qui est dans la mémoire
collective pour pour ceux qui ont
quelques souvenirs de l'école primaire
c'était en 1358 et cette année-là les
paysans s'étaient révolt et et sont
descendus sur Paris et et venaient pour
l'essentiel de Picardi bon ça c'est mal
terminé on va arrêter l'analogie ici
parce qu'ils ont fini par être massacré
purement et simplement je pense qu'on va
pas en arriver là mais ce qu'on ce qu'on
a voulu signifier c'est que il y a un
moment d'histoire et et d'histoire qui
se répète et dans les moments où la
province décide d'aller à Paris c'est
que l'instant est toujours
particulièrement grave voilà ce qu'on a
voulu dire avec ce titre ce matin une
question pour Pascal grunny Jean-Marc
mais écoutez depuis tout à l'heure je
vous écoute bonjour madame gruni je vous
écoute je vous entends beaucoup parler
d'agriculture d'écologie aussi et il y a
un mot que j'ai absolument pas entendu
depuis depuis ce matin
sur le plateau c'est la mondialisation
or les
agriculteurs dans l'INE bah il y a le
sucre vous en avez dit quelques mot on
fait du sucre ailleur sur la planète
plus largement on on achète on achète de
l'agneau de Nouvelle-Zélande en France
qui est qui est une viande qui n'est pas
de bonne qualité alors que celle de la
la Baie de Somme ou de la baie du
mont-smichel pour sortir de la Picardie
est bien meilleur et et voilà donc la
mondialisation les fruits et légumes qui
viennent du bout du monde tout ça on n a
pas parlé depuis ce matin j'aurais voulu
votre sentiment là-dessus parce que on
sait que il y a une mondialisation qui a
aussi aidé l'agriculture à un moment
donné mais il y a voilà le dossier est
très complexe mais votre avis là-dessus
est-ce qu'on doit sortir des traités
comment comment on gère ce problème pour
rentabiliser notre
agriculture alors il y a deux choses en
fait parce que on a on a cette
concurrence en fait mondiale hors une
Union européenne et aujourd'hui en plus
on a une concurrence à l'intérieur de de
l'Union européenne parce que la pack la
politique agricole commune elle est
presque plus commune puisque maintenant
on a des plans stratégiques nationaux
sur le plan des des des traité du du
mercosour par
exemple en fait ce qu'il y a c'est que
déjà les normes ne sont pas identique
comment on fait pour accepter d'importer
pour accepter dans le cadre du libre
échange de faire rentrer des produits
qui sont pas aux mêmes normes que chez
nous c'est déjà la première des choses
parce que là on a des concurrences
déloyales et au niveau des des prix
également donc donc moi sur sur tous ces
ces traités effectivement on a une
opposition assez forte et surtout
l'agriculture ne doit pas toujours être
la variable d'ajustement parce que c'est
ce que c'est ce qu'on voit souvent après
les échanges mondiaux bien évidemment ça
existe mais pas toujours l'agriculture
en fait qui en fait qui en fait les
frais ouais mais je pardon je recite
Marc fen mais parce que évidemment on
l'entend beaucoup en ce moment il dit
que les traités de libre échange il
profitent aussi aux agriculteurs
français qu' y a énormément
d'exportation et que si on bloque ces
traités ça pénalisera l'agriculture
française complètement mais ce qu'il y a
c'est que les échanges doivent être au
même niveau on doit avoir les mêmes
normes est-ce que les Français
aujourd'hui finalement on leur propose
de manger moins bien surtout pour ceux
qui ont moins les les moyens avec des
produits qui sont importés et là ça
c'est ça c'est pas c'est pas normal
c'est pas acceptable en fait oui sinon
sur les échanges bien sûr exportations
moi j'ai j'ai comment dans mon
département du champagne n'est-ce pas et
euh et donc si on ferme nos portes
effectivement aux
importations le champagne le vin qui
sont quand même dans l'équilibre de la
balance commerciale très important donc
donc on est d'accord mais même normes
mêmes exigences en fait à l'entrée dans
dans les pays merci Jean-Marc et la une
du Courrier Picard on l'a vu c'est la
grande Jacquerie c'est àire ce matin
dans votre journal merci Jean-Marc
chevaucher d'avoir été avec nous un
dernier mot Pascal grenny puisque demain
il y aura le discours de politique
générale de Gabriel Atal devant
l'Assemblée ce sera mercredi devant le
Sénat alors évidemment on attend les
réponses sur la question agricole mais
pas que hier en andréloir il a dit qu'il
était déterminé à avancer pour mieux
valoriser le travail que ce serait le
cœur de son discours c'est la bonne
ligne pour vous bah il y a beaucoup de
choses hein donc on attend en fait du
Premier ministre qui donne un vrai cap
qui parle de réforme alors le travail
bien entendu on a fait un texte de loi
sur sur le plein emploi on nous avait
promis effectivement ce texte sur le
travail oui c'est important il y a pas
que ça il y a la santé il y a tout ce
qui concerne aussi le pouvoir d'achat
donc on a vraiment d'autres attentes
aussi la sécurité la sécurité pour pour
tous les jeunes la délinquence des des
mineurs donc il y a énormément de de
réponses qui qui sont attendues les
grand discours ça c'est sûr que Monsieur
le Premier Ministre Gabriel hatal est
très fort là-dessus je ne doute pas que
ça ce sera toujours de bon niveau mais
en revanche c'est après et ce cap quoi
qui qui s'y tienne s'il en a un un mot
un mot puisque vous parliez vous faisiez
tout à l'heure référence à la loi
immigration Emmanuel Macron l' l'a
promulgué ce weekend malgré les
dispositions censurées par le Conseil
constitutionnel il n en a donc pas tenu
compte en tout cas des propositions LR
il y aura pas de nouveau projet de loi
c'est ce qu'a dit Gérald armanin il a eu
raison de le promulguer aussi vite et et
malgré le fait que vos propositions
n'ont pas été retenues ah ben ça je
trouve ça dommage mais c'est surtout nos
propositions qui n'ont pas été retenu
moi je me demande des fois s'il
rencontre les mêmes français que nous il
y avait une telle attente en en fait
dans partout en France hein puisque avec
les collègues on discute beaucoup et là
tout ce qui était justement qui pouvait
permettre de réguler de de remettre
aussi parce que souvent les les Français
trouvent que c'est injuste par exemple
que une personne qui arrive sur le
territoire récupère tout de suite des
prestations euh bah tout ça en fait ça a
été vidé en fait dans dans le texte
c'est dommage merci Pascal Gruny merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure